but like women we can't make sex tapes
we're too emotional right we're too
sensitive like when I were to make a sex
tape of some guy you know from like five
years ago popping it now I wouldn't be
like oh yeah I'm gonna fight him on
Facebook I'm just not like that like I
have girlfriends who old text message
naked photos of themselves to their man
which I guess the whole point of that is
to be like oh here's what's waiting for
you at home big boy photos if I was to
do it here's what's waiting for you at
home photo shoot I would take some
pictures of the freakin dishes okay the
bills right now my vagina's not waiting
for you at home at all trying to book me
an acting job it is very busy right now
it's not sexy like guys girls are sexy
now I'm not a sexy girlfriend all I'm
doing relationships is fight that's all
I ever do in relationships but the thing
is that women we are amazing fighters
right we are we are like emotional
ninjas right our favorite tactic is the
silent treatment that is our jam right
our man pissed off he pissed me off I'm
not gonna talk to him for the rest of
the day I'm gonna show him ladies the
silent treatment is not a punishment
it's a freaking reward okay he's like ah
thank God she shut the hell up oh my god
I love the silent treatment I get to
watch SportsCenter again today I'm gonna
forget her birthday every year ladies
next time your man pisses you off do not
give him the silent treatment instead go
google the most important game of the
season sitting next to him during that
game and just ask as many fucking
questions
as possible I don't understand who's
that guy in the striped shirt does he
work at full Locker
I don't understand why are they all
wearing the same outfit what are we
gonna have a baby
eventually he will shoot himself in the
face and you fucking win that argument
[Applause]